let me ask you a quick question yeah why
don't you have a podcast yet you can't
take people with strong personality at
the end of the day yes I interrupted you
but you couldn't easily LED that into a
discussion that's what a good podcaster
would do and right now you should
embarrass yourself in front of all your
subscribers yeah maybe something like
[__] literally like you you have the
worst attitude ever you're [__]
grumpy and listen none of the girls that
even enjoy themselves there is bloody
[__] dead
and all the time I don't know who the
[__] you think you are thinking you're
moving your hair like a [__] chicken
like [__] up go back in a [__]
Farm I don't know what the [__] is wrong
with you saying oh like oh go go who the
[__] speaks like that are you mad you
know what you're very lucky I didn't
flip out [__] camera and embarrassed
you because I could easily expose you
right now I've got bad contacts to take
your whole [__] career down the [__]
up at the at the end of the day like why
did you why did you call me here then
John's trying to say you're the one you
and your stupid guy call me here don't
bring me back again then why if you
can't have a whole conversation then
don't have a [__] podcast are you mad
because listen I will [__] draw you
out I'm not that [__] to [__] with